London in the 1960s everyone had a story
about Christ I come here for a proper
shoot out a movie that rolling pick the
Pope me a cake which do I mind if I
fight that way yeah these are the Kray
twins Ronald and Reginald you take my
breath away you must be Francis hey
chief finger we look like sea life being
a gangster I like the money and the
respect your brother Rob is Island and
psychopathic he's off his rocker
well no no no no sir out right it's a so
much like a West you're talking about
being gangsters which is what we are the
Mafia's made inquiries London is going
to be the Las Vegas of Europe we can
handle it you come to Philadelphia it's
a nice Italian girl
we'll get a foot I prefer boys it's had
its sometimes great but I am NOT
prejudiced you got a lot of balls and
let that kid me and my proper we're
gonna rule London
got laughing ow yeah are you mad
do something about run I can't do that
he's my brother
I wanna lie flat if she knows too many
things us we're going down into the
sewer
after the crates my lucky for my brother
is how I miss it myself
what about your loyalty to me crime is
still a business you don't want a war
yeah a direct state
listen to yourself one you're not blood
is thicker than water
you know if I do anything a lot of
myself you
you live in London a she doesn t crates
willing Ronald and Reginald